[Musique]
les élus du conseil départemental se
réunissent en séance plinière afin
d'examiner les orientation budgétaire
2024 une feuille de route qui s'inscrit
dans un contexte budgétaire contraint
pour le moment on tient on tient notre
projet après Ben dans les perspectives
qui vont venir on attend une baisse des
taux d'intérêt on attend une reprise de
de de la reprise économique he donc
annoncé 1,4% pour 202 4 de croissance
économique donc ce sont ces éléments là
qui sont importants pour nous parce
qu'il faut rappeler que si nous avons
des dépenses qui structurellement
augmentent du fait notamment de
l'augmentation de la population du
vieillissement de la population nous
avons des recettes elles qui reposent
sur un contexte plutôt économique et
donc et donc c'est des fiscalités
indirectes et qu'il nous faut en même
temps surveiller de prê et donc c'est le
développement de l'économie qui
permettra aussi de garantir un bon
équilibre de nos comptes 10 grandes
ambitions porteront l'action
départementale dans le domaine du social
du développement humain de l'agriculture
de la transition écologique et solidaire
de la coopération régionale et de la
modernisation de l'action publique le
caractère social du budget de la
collectivité est indéniable c'est dans
l'histoire c'est dans nos missions c'est
la loi qui le prévoit et c'est pour cela
que dans ce que nous allons faire en
matière sociale nous allons d'abord bien
évidemment penser au plus fragile à
l'accompagnement des public les plus
fragiles les jeunes en
particulier avec le déploiement de
diverses actions sur le territoire pour
un meilleur accompagnement une meilleure
insertion des personnes notamment des
jeunes ensuite nous pensons aux
personnes en situation de handicap et
vous l'avez vu la semaine dernière j'ai
travaillé avec la ministre pour mettre
en place un plan de rattrapage qui veut
que sur les six prochaines années nous
allons pouvoir rattraper le retard de la
Réunion en matière de place d'accueil
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap les personnes âgées aussi parce
que nous avions il y a un an pareil avec
l'ancienne ministre travailler et mise
en place ce plan ce qui veut dire que
l'année 2024 sera consacrée au pilotage
du plan rattrapage pour les personnes en
situation de handicap comme pour les
personnes âgées l'assemblée plinière
s'est clôuré avec une intervention du
Père Pedro il lance un appel à la
solidarité entre les pays de la zone
Océan Indien ça veut dire les bons amis
je souhaite que tous les réonnais soient
des bons amis que nous soyons tous la
famille humain que nous pu être tolérant
les uns avec les autres et àarion vous
donner un exemple parce que vous savez
cohabiter en tant que en tant que ethnie
il y a
différents personnes de différents
origines et aussi de religion et vous
savez vivre ensemble je vous dis merci
pour l'exemple que vous donnez à l'océan
Indien voilà merci puissionsnous prendre
aussi votre votre esprit dans ce
domaine